Цей закон називають історичним.
Німецький парламент ухвалив документ, який скорочує і спрощує
отримання німецького паспорта для іноземців.
Розповідаємо про ключові зміни.
Претендувати на німецький паспорт
можна буде вже через п'ять років проживання в Німеччині.
Донині було вісім років.
Якщо людина має так звані "особливі інтеграційні досягнення",
то зможе подаватися на громадянство вже за три роки.
Досі було шість.
Новий закон, який ухвалили, але який ще не набув чинності,
надає можливість натуралізації за три роки,
якщо будуть виконані певні умови.
Це означає, що якщо українські біженці
приїхали до Німеччини у 2022 році, то теоретично
вони можуть подавати заявки з 2025-го, але, звісно,
вони повинні виконати спеціальні вимоги.
Наприклад, це високий рівень німецької мови,
активна участь у волонтерстві
або значні професійні досягнення.
Особливим досягненням буде, наприклад,
сертифікат С1 про знання німецької мови.
Це означає, що людина виконує вимоги щодо мовних навичок
і навіть більше: вона довела, що прагне
якнайшвидше інтегруватися.
Ще одне особливе досягнення - здобуття освіти в Німеччині.
А також, якщо ви працюєте на громадських засадах
у німецьких організаціях, берете активну участь у їхній діяльності.
Звісно, рішення ухвалюватиме конкретний чиновник:
є тут особливе інтеграційне досягнення чи немає.
Ще одна ключова зміна: охочі отримати німецький паспорт
не повинні будуть відмовлятися від свого первинного громадянства -
наприклад, українського. Раніше зберегти
український паспорт можна було тільки як виняток.
Іноземці, які бажають отримати німецький паспорт,
повинні самі себе забезпечувати.
Що це означає для українських біженців,
які отримують допомогу від держави?
Добре, якщо претенденти на громадянство
мають безстроковий трудовий договір.
Держава повинна пересвідчитися, що люди
фінансово забезпечені, тобто самі стоять на ногах,
а не знову подаватимуть заявки на отримання соцвиплат
після того, як набудуть громадянство.
Експертка наводить приклад: якщо ви влаштувалися на роботу
місяць тому і маєте трудовий договір на пів року,
то це суттєво зменшить шанси на отримання паспорта.
Найкраще мати безстроковий трудовий договір,
тобто довести, що матимете робоче місце в майбутньому.
Якщо хоча б один із батьків-іноземців прожив у Німеччині п'ять років,
то його діти зможуть отримати німецьке громадянство.
Коли дитина стане повнолітньою, їй більше не доведеться
обирати між німецьким громадянством і тим,
яке вона успадкувала від батьків.
Громадянами Німеччини не зможуть стати антисеміти,
расисти та інші особи, які зневажають людську гідність.
Паспорти не надаватимуть тим, хто
не визнає рівноправність чоловіків і жінок.
Чоловіки, які мають кількох дружин,
теж не зможуть стати німецькими громадянами.
Населення Німеччини старішає.
Робочих рук бракує.
Німецький уряд намагається заохотити
переселятися в країну фахівців із-за кордону.
Міністерка внутрішніх справ Ненсі Фезер каже, що
новий закон має стимулювати інтеграцію мігрантів
у німецьке суспільство, а не створювати їм перешкоди.
Закон про громадянство ухвалили у другому читанні.
Тепер його має схвалити Бундесрат - орган, що
представляє федеральні землі.
Потім закон підпише президент Німеччини.
Після цього документ стане чинним.
Експерти припускають, що після набуття чинності
нового закону близько восьми мільйонів людей
зможуть претендувати на німецький паспорт.
Черги у відомствах у справах іноземців
можуть стати ще довшими, ніж досі.